when it comes to horror movies not every
shrill shriek from its stars is fake
more often than not production on a
thriller peak is a screwed sailing this
any other genre film but every so often
the fright factor bleeds over into real
life in the cases of these scary movies
some of their cast members were left
shaken by what they'd experienced on set
a Clockwork Orange Stanley Kubrick's
highly controversial adaptation of A
Clockwork Orange
is disturbing enough for the viewer let
alone for the actor who started so much
my little journey for the famous
brainwashing scene in the film lead
actor Malcolm McDowell allowed his eyes
to be pinned open to every take
unfortunately McDowell didn't leave
unscathed
the physical torment caused him to
suffer from temporary blindness and a
scratched cornea and it took decades for
him to be able to watch the film and
actually enjoy Kubrick's work I would
like to smash up the birds while filming
the birds Alfred Hitchcock absolutely
tormented his die actress Tippi Hedren
both on and off set through manipulation
sexual slurs and obsessive behaviors the
notoriously tough director made Hedren
live to regret her decision to star in
his film the tipping point for Hedren
though was when Hitchcock lied about the
use of real birds in a particular scene
instead of the mechanical birds used in
the rest of the film Hedren was duped
into acting with live ones that were
held at her over a week of filming
she left her set bruised bloodied and
emotionally scarred they really didn't
need five days of that that was that was
just kind of I don't know what it was
curled Amy it was mean psycho
Phoebe hadron wasn't the only one to
experience a real fright on the set of a
Hitchcock film Janet Leigh was never
quite the same
after starring is Marion crane in psycho
either she was so traumatized after
watching herself in the famous shower
scene that she became too afraid to take
showers and from that point forward only
took bogs I don't take showers unless
there's no other way to bait and in that
case the door is open if they're sliding
doors the curtain is open if it's
curtain and the door to the bathroom was
opened so that I can see out Rosemary's
Baby Mia Farrow went through quite a few
traumatizing experiences while working
on Roman Polanski's American film debut
for his Mary's baby a strict vegetarian
pharaoh was asked by Polanski if she
wouldn't mind eating raw chicken liver
for a scene little did she know she
would be forced to consume it over and
over again for different takes that's
the kind of shooting experience that
definitely leaves a bad taste in an
actress's mouth the Blair Witch Project
while the Blair Witch Project is a movie
that's probably laughed at more than it
actually scares people nowadays the
disturbing ways in which the directors
haunted the cast of frightening enough
on their own filmed over an 8 day
camping trip there was little
interaction between the cast and
directors sure they had daily meetings
to provide the actors with more supplies
and instructions for where to go next
but the trio that starred in the pic
were mostly on their own so to
authentically scare the cast directors
also stalked the actors during the day
rattled their tents while they were
sleeping at night and intentionally gave
them less food as the day's progressed
so they became more and more angry and
exhausted The Exorcism of Emily Rose
Jennifer Carpenter might have been find
with all the sinister surgical
procedures going down on Dexter but the
actress got a case of the spooks during
the production of The Exorcism of Emily
Rose while she was filming the religious
thriller some strange things started
happening to her after hours she told
dread central two or three times when I
was going to sleep my radio came on by
itself the only time it scared me was
once because it was really loud and it
was pail jams alive she wasn't the only
one to experience such supernatural
phenomena on the set either co-star
Laura Linney's television repeatedly
turned itself on at night during the
shoot
carpenter lady chalked up these
happenings to some electrical issue with
the hotel they were staying my stereo
would come on really loudly and I got a
little listening to it I wouldn't even
know I don't know if there was a short
in this in the plug or what but it
happened but she was also really glad
the clerk didn't read 3 a.m.
when it happened since that was such a
horrifyingly significant time in the
movie the conjuring the real-life ghost
hunting story of edy and Lorraine Warren
is freaking enough to put anyone on edge
but Vera Farmiga knew very little about
her real-life character counterpart
before signing the dotted line on the
contrary and receiving her first
paranormal encounter as a bonus the
actress revealed that during her first
round of research into Warren's work she
had a brush with the beyond after she
hung up the phone with directed James
Wan as she told cinema blend she opened
her laptop to find three digital claw
marks from the upper-right diagonally to
the lower left those marks would make a
second unsettling arrival in filmmakers
conjuring experience the day after she
finished shooting the first film and
returned to her home in New York she
woke up to find a similar set of
markings on her thigh she explained it
was these three very distinct what looks
like four marks that long nails or thin
fingertips could make she chose not to
give in to fear of the moment and signed
on to the second film which would give a
different cast mate a case of the creeps
Patrick Wilson was no newbie to the
scream scene before he joined the
conjuring series but the second
installment of his ghost hunting
endeavor did freak him out the most
according to him there was a pretty
trippy moment during the production
involving a curtain haunting that led
the crew to bring in a priest to bless
the set
he told Metro it was a huge curtain that
went from the floor to the ceiling which
was sort of waving violently and there
was no door open or fan on no nothing
you didn't even hear any air but you
watched these cones sort of violently
going Wilson considers himself a skeptic
but all of his supernatural screenplay
may have gotten the better of him at
this point because he's admitted to
believing his own house may be haunted
now he told the independent I've heard
people on two different occasions say
they've heard kids laughter in the
middle of the night in my house talk
about taking work home with you thanks
for watching click to lure icons to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you